In this video, we'll design
the optimization problem
that the operating room
manager would need to solve.
The decision to be made is
how many operating rooms
to assign each
department on each day.
This means that we need
to define integer decision
variables x_jk.
x_jk will represent the
number of operating rooms
department j is
allocated on day k.
So here j can take values such
as ophthalmology, gynecology,
general surgery, and so on.
Whereas k would take values
like Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
and so on.
The objective of
this problem will
be to maximize the percent
of target allocation hours
that each department
is actually allocated.
So if target allocation hours
are t_j for department j,
then we want to maximize the sum
of 8*x_jk divided by t_j over
all departments and
days of the week.
Let's break this down.
For example, if
otolaryngology has
a target of 37.3
hours per week--
that means t_j equals to
37.3-- and we allocate them
4 operating rooms, then their
percent of target allocation
hours is equal to
8 times 4, that
is, they got 32 hours,
divided by the 37.3 hours
they asked for.
So they got 85.8%
of what they wanted.
And we try to maximize
this percentage value
for every department.
So that's why we sum
over all departments
and all days of the week.
Let's continue on
to the constraints.
Remember that Mount Sinai
has 10 operating rooms.
Therefore, at most
10 operating rooms
can be assigned
on any given day.
Also, the number of operating
rooms allocated to a department
on a given day cannot exceed
the number of surgery teams that
the department has
available that day.
And as we said before, we must
meet department daily minimums
and maximums as well as
weekly minimums and maximums.
Let's turn these
constraints into math.
So the first constraint is
that at most 10 operating rooms
can be assigned
on any given day.
Let's consider
Monday for example.
That means that x
for ophthalmology
on Monday plus x for
gynecology on Monday
plus x for oral
surgery on Monday
plus x for
otolaryngology on Monday
plus x for general
surgery on Monday
must add up to something
less than or equal to 10.
We would have a
similar constraint
for Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday and Friday.
The next set of constraints is
that the number of operating
rooms allocated to a department
on a given day cannot exceed
the number of surgery teams
that are available that day.
So for example, for
gynecology on Friday
there are 3 teams available.
That means that x gynecology
Friday must be between 0 and 3.
For oral surgery on Wednesday
it must be between 0 and 0
because the oral surgeon is only
in on Tuesdays and Thursdays.
The next set of
constraints is that we
must meet department daily
minimums and maximums.
For example, the general
surgery department on Tuesday
requires between 0
and 6 operating rooms.
We would have a similar
constraint for every department
and for every day of the week.
We also need to meet department
weekly minimums and maximums.
So for example, the
ophthalmology department
has a minimum of 3 and a
maximum of 6 operating rooms
that it needs in any given week.